hello i'm lisa vanderpump and i'm here
with buzzfeed
and i'm ready to talk about my first
my first job was in a sweet shop
when i was about 14 i used to work there
after school
and i used to work there on saturdays
and i cannot believe that the owner of
the sweet shop because i used to eat
most of the sweets
would actually let me have the keys and
open up the shop on my own
and so i would be sitting there selling
candy or as you call it we call it
sweets
and magazines yeah on my own i've had a
job since i was 13 14.
i'm very industrious i bought my own
apartment with no help with my parents
by time i was 19.
well i think i was in london and i think
it was a car phone rather than a cell
phone
i remember ken had one one of those
heavy weights that you had to
carry around which looked ridiculous now
when you think about it
but i had a car phone it was such a
luxury
and i can't believe that we ever used to
survive without
phones but yes it was in i had a
mercedes 450 sl
probably about 22 and i had a car phone
but you know what i did used to have a
little pink
motorola i still missed that phone a
little fat pink
motorola i wish i could get that back
it's kind of embarrassing to say now
because i don't really find him
attractive at all
well maybe if i met him but it was david
cassidy
but there didn't seem to be many
celebrities but it was like we were in
england it was either donny osmond
or david cassidy those are the two
choices
my first dog was uh samoyed and i got it
as soon as i left home
and her name was velvet
oh no my first car i bought when i was
16
i was too young to drive i bought it for
400
it was a triumph herald and again i was
pretty industrious
and had a good work ethic so i bought it
on my own my parents didn't spoil us at
all they didn't buy us anything like
that
i ended up selling it and buying a mini
cooper s which is kind of cool now
at the time everybody had minis but yeah
i had a little white mini i used to tear
around london
i used to think i was like driving on a
racing track thank god i'm still alive
no idea how i survived that in london
well when i met ken he had a wine bar
restaurant called corpse in south
kensington
so i guess that'd be my first one i met
him when i was 21.
they were a pretty you know gregarious
bunch that's what they were like it was
hollywood
and they were trying to make it in
hollywood they grew on me i would see
them when i'd go into the restaurant
starcy
kristen sandville worked in villa blanca
and came over to sir
kristen was dating sandoval stasi
was with jax who didn't come work for me
till later
and i think being at a restaurant was
just basically a stepping stone and
sometimes they acted like that
it wasn't their career choice let's put
it that way
my first date might be at a party
if somebody actually turned out to be
gay which is rather disappointing i hope
it wasn't me that persuaded them
my first date was ken i met him through
my brother
he'd known my brother for quite a long
time my first date with kim was in a
restaurant called san frediano
he'd asked me out prior to that and i'd
said no
and he ended up coming to my apartment
to see me he said i'm taking you out for
general went to a place a very famous
restaurant in south kensington it was
almost love at first sight
but remember i got engaged after six
weeks married within three months
i think it was in new york camille and
and kyle were fighting and it was just
so intense i remember thinking what the
hell am i doing here i've got to get out
of here this is not a world i want to be
in
and they were fighting and she said
you're such a [ __ ] liar camille i was
like
oh my god that's when it took a bit of a
turn for me and i went to bed and i
called ken in tears saying
i can't do this they're crazy i was
right actually
well there's so much advice had given us
buying i mean it's very difficult job
you've really got to love what you do
because it's all ours that god sends
and i think really pay attention to the
ambiance as much as the food
make sure that the surroundings is
really
as important as the food that's one of
the key
things of our success
i remember when i went to new york and
real housewives had just come out
and i was going into one of the news
buildings in new york
the show literally just come out and
suddenly anderson cooper turned around
to me of course he's very close to andy
kern
but i didn't know that at the time he
said i am such a big fan
and i thought hold on you're like a war
hero
and a war correspondent and i'm an idiot
and you're telling me
you're a fan of mine i like this it was
just the funniest thing it was anderson
cooper it was 10 years ago
he was known for being you know in the
front line and
kind of always like ducking bullets and
then he was telling me
this woman that appeared on reality
television that he was a fan
so that was kind of pretty amazing
the first time i knew i was famous is
when i was in fred siegel's
and i was having lunch and i'd been on
the show about
a couple of years and i went outside and
they were taking pictures and i was just
like
oh my god who's here and they were like
you are
i was like what really that was yeah the
beginning of something that really was
that was the funniest thing i had no
idea that anybody would show up to take
my picture
oh god there was um the real housewives
beverly hills that they said
i'm a liar i'm a pimp i'm
a arms dealer max isn't my son
i ran a brothel um
what was it there was loads of things
they said about me in the second season
everything negative yeah they threw at
me in the second season
i was just like am i even going to
dignify any any of this with a response
they said that i would go around selling
arms on
my boat in the south of france like
where do these people come from
probably friends i don't know because i
don't watch a lot of television
but every time i watch that show i feel
like i've never seen it before so i
don't understand where all these
episodes keep coming from
well it's a beautiful poignant show that
tells the story of these
you know incredible animals getting
their second chance
at life it's also a human story as well
about making the right match i'm just
passionate about this project because
and pump dogs has been open for five
years now
and i have to thank my staff for that dr
john cessa has gone above and beyond
we've just loved this show you know just
seeing it shine a light
on rescue seeing so many of these
gorgeous furry people getting their
second
chance at life and it's a heartwarming
emotionally provocative
show i think people are gonna love it
well thank you so much buzzfeed
please watch over served on e and watch
vanderpump dogs which
is streaming on peacock thank you so
much
you